How to Win Friends and Influence People. First published in 1936. When you read this thing, you can see why it is number one. Dale Carnegie writes in this pepped up style. You don't think of the word "moxie" much anymore, but when you read this, it is typical. In preparation for writing this book, he read everything he could find on the subject. Then he lists all this stuff that he and his trained researcher read to figure out how the great leaders of all ages had dealt with people.
《人性的弱点》（How to Win Friends and Influence People）。该书于1936年首次出版。当你读到这本书时，你就能明白它为何能排在第一位。戴尔·卡耐基用这种充满活力的文风进行写作。你现在可能很少听到“魄力”（moxie）这个词了，但当你读这本书时，你会发现这是典型的那个时代的词汇。在准备写这本书时，他阅读了当时他能找到的关于该主题的一切资料。然后，他列出了他和训练有素的研究人员所阅读的所有材料，以弄清楚古往今来的伟大领袖们是如何与人打交道的。
He says, "I recalled that we read over 100 biographies of Theodore Roosevelt alone. We were determined to spare no time, no expense, to discover every practical idea that anyone had ever used throughout the ages for winning friends and influencing people."
他说：“我记得我们仅仅是关于西奥多·罗斯福的传记就读了100多本。我们下定决心，不惜任何时间和金钱，去挖掘古往今来任何人所用过的、每一个关于赢得朋友和影响他人的实用理念。”
Anyway, on page 61 of the edition that I have, Dale Carnegie tells one of the many, many stories he uses to illustrate the very main idea that underlies the whole book. He says, "I often went fishing up in Maine during the summer. Personally, I am very fond of strawberries and cream, but I have found that for some strange reason, fish prefer worms. So when I went fishing, I didn't think about what I wanted, I thought about what they wanted. I didn't bait the hook with strawberries and cream, rather I dangled a worm or a grasshopper in front of the fish and said, wouldn't you like to have that? Why not use the same common sense when fishing for people?"
总之，在我手头这本书的第61页，戴尔·卡耐基讲述了他用来阐明贯穿全书核心理念的众多故事中的一个。他说：“我夏天常去缅因州钓鱼。我个人非常喜欢吃草莓配奶油，但我发现出于某种奇怪的原因，鱼更喜欢蚯蚓。所以当我去钓鱼时，我不会去想我想要什么，我会去想鱼想要什么。我不会用草莓和奶油做鱼饵，而是会把蚯蚓或蚱蜢悬在鱼面前说，你想要这个吗？钓人时为什么不运用同样的常识呢？”
To win friends and influence people, Dale Carnegie says over and over in the book, think about what they want. People, he says, are basically only interested in themselves. And if you can get yourself to the point where you are genuinely interested in them and what they like and what they want, then they will like you, and they will do your bidding.
戴尔·卡耐基在书中反复强调，要赢得朋友并影响他人，就要考虑他们想要什么。他说，人们基本上只对自己感兴趣。如果你能让自己做到真正对他们、对他们所喜欢的事物、对他们想要的东西感兴趣，那么他们就会喜欢你，并按照你的意愿行事。
So imagine you are 11 years old and you dad notices that you don't bring many friends around the house. And he takes you aside and he gives you a copy of this actual book. This happened. This happened to Paul Feig, growing up in suburban Michigan.
试想一下，你今年11岁，你父亲注意到你没带什么朋友回家。于是他把你拉到一边，送了你一本这本书。这件事确实发生了，发生在密歇根州郊区长大的保罗·菲格（Paul Feig）身上。
At first I didn't know what to think. First of all, if you've ever seen the book, it's got this picture of Dale Carnegie on the front, who is somewhere in his 60s or 70s wearing those Mr. Menace glasses. The Dennis the Menace's dad used to wear with this kind of white, slicked back hair. He looked like every guy that was in my dad's Kiwanis with him. And didn't seem to me like a guy who particularly would have that many friends or much influence over people. But he had written the book.
起初我不知道该怎么想。首先，如果你见过这本书，它的封面上印着戴尔·卡耐基的照片，当时他大概六七十岁，戴着那种“淘气阿丹”（Dennis the Menace）爸爸常戴的眼镜，梳着那种白色的后梳油头。他看起来就像我父亲所在基瓦尼国际社（Kiwanis）里的每一个人。在我看来，他并不像是一个会拥有很多朋友或对人有很大影响力的人。但他确实写了这本书。
So my father went onto make this speech basically, about how now that I was getting older-- I was 11 years old-- that it was time for me to kind of get social skills that he assumed I didn't have.
于是我父亲开始发表长篇大论，大意是说我已经长大了——我当时11岁——是时候让我获得他认为我所欠缺的社交技巧了。
Now, in fact, in school, Paul had plenty of friends. He was kind of a class cut up. And his way of winning friends was the same as other kids. He talked about what they saw on TV and tried to be funny. It was just around the house that he was quiet and withdrawn. But he figured, he wanted to be more popular. He wanted more friends. So he decided to try out some of the techniques in the book.
事实上，保罗在学校里有很多朋友。他是班里的开心果。他赢得朋友的方式和其他孩子一样。他谈论他们在电视上看到的内容，努力变得风趣。只是在家里，他比较安静和孤僻。但他想，他希望能更受欢迎，他想要更多的朋友。于是他决定尝试书中提到的一些技巧。
And I went through these and principle number one was become genuinely interested in other people. Principle number two was smile. Principle number three was remember that a person's name is to that person the sweetest and most important sound in any language.
我读了这些内容，原则一就是：真诚地对他人感兴趣。原则二：微笑。原则三：记住一个人的名字是任何语言中最悦耳、最重要的声音。
Yeah, I was wondering about that one in particular. If as an 11 year old you tried to employ that one.
是的，我当时特别好奇这一点。如果你作为一个11岁的孩子尝试运用这一条的话。
Well, the hard thing was when you're 11 years old, the only thing you ever call anybody is by their last name. So I was kind of confused as to whether that sort of applied. And this started a bit of a panic in me. Because I suddenly didn't know. Well, maybe people would like me better if I did that. And so I remember getting to school the next day and my friend Dave Flurry, who I had always called Flurry, I remember going up to him and going, hey, David. How's it going? And he gave me the strangest look.
嗯，困难的是，当你11岁时，你称呼任何人的唯一方式就是叫他们的姓。所以我当时很困惑这是否适用。这让我产生了一点恐慌。因为我突然不知道了，嗯，也许如果我那样做，人们会更喜欢我。所以我记得第二天到了学校，我对我一直叫他“弗勒里”（Flurry）的朋友戴夫·弗勒里（Dave Flurry）说：“嘿，戴维，最近怎么样？”他给了我一个极其奇怪的眼神。
Paul used techniques from the book to try to talk to girls. Asking them about themselves, what their dad's did for a living. Just showing an interest in them as the book suggests. And it just sort of freaked them out. Kids do not talk like that.
保罗利用书中的技巧试图与女生交谈。问她们关于自己的事情，问她们父亲是做什么工作的。正如书中所建议的那样，只是对她们表现出兴趣。结果把她们给吓坏了。小孩子是不会那样说话的。
And I would sit at lunch with my friends. And they would be on a story and I would want to throw in, as I normally would, but kind of went, oh wait. No, I should sit back and listen and really be attentive. And would nod and go, oh, oh. Then what did your brother do? Oh, he punched you. Really? And what happened then? And I became this sort of mini analyst where I was sort of trying to get kids to tell me their innermost secrets.
午餐时我会和朋友们坐在一起。他们会讲一个故事，我本想像往常一样插嘴，但突然想到，噢，等等。不，我应该坐下来听，真正专注地倾听。我会点头说：“噢，噢。然后你兄弟做了什么？噢，他打了你？真的吗？那后来发生了什么？”我变成了一个小分析师，试图让孩子们告诉我他们内心深处的秘密。
But what happened was my father kept checking in with me at night. He'd go, so did you read that book? Have you tried any of these things out? So I felt like I needed more proof.
但结果是，我父亲每天晚上都会检查我的进度。他会问：“那么，你读那本书了吗？你尝试过其中的任何方法吗？”所以我感到我需要更多的证据。
More proof to take to your dad?
更多的证据带给你父亲看？
Yes, I needed a tangible thing to show my father that I had become popular and was winning friends and influencing people.
是的，我需要一个切实的东西向我父亲证明我已经变得受欢迎，并且正在赢得朋友和影响他人。
So when Paul's teacher decided to do an exercise where they elected a class president, he ran. And he won. And his father was very, very pleased. The book was working. There was just one problem.
所以当保罗的老师决定进行一次班长竞选活动时，他参加了。他赢了。他父亲非常非常高兴。这本书奏效了。只是有一个问题。
One of the things I hadn't banked on was that as class president, I actually had to do something. I was so not into this. I was just hating it because I just wanted to get back to my life with my friends.
我没预料到的一件事是，作为班长，我实际上必须做点什么。我一点也不想做这个。我讨厌它，因为我只想回到我和朋友们的生活中去。
Well, the teacher was dissatisfied, and the students were dissatisfied. And the teacher suddenly decided, well, you know what? And she got up and she said, there is a process in our political system in this country called impeachment. And she looked out and she said, how does everyone feel about our class president Paul?
嗯，老师不满意，学生们也不满意。老师突然决定，嗯，你知道吗？她站起来说，我们国家的政治体系中有一个程序叫做弹劾。她环顾四周说，大家对我们的班长保罗感觉如何？
What would he say to his father? The whole experience with Dale Carnegie actually left Paul with fewer friends and less influence over people. It was confusing, all the ideas the book put into his head.
他会对他父亲说什么呢？整段关于戴尔·卡耐基的经历实际上让保罗的朋友变少了，对人的影响力也变小了。这让人感到困惑，书灌输给他的所有想法。
I couldn't get out of my head the fact that my dad had given this to me and the fact that he was so concerned that I didn't have friends. And so I started getting nervous. Like, well, maybe he's seeing something that I don't know. It was strange. I would start to see things that weren't there, like somebody would sort of laugh at what I say and they'd turn away to look at something. And suddenly I was envisioning that as they're turning away with their back to me, they're making this sort of face and rolling their eyes of like, what an idiot. And started noticing in the teacher that when I would raise my hand and answer a question, something in her face that kind of was like she was tolerating me.
我无法摆脱这个事实：我父亲把这本书给了我，而且他非常担心我没有朋友。所以我开始变得紧张。比如，嗯，也许他看到了什么我不知道的东西。这很奇怪。我会开始看到并不存在的东西，比如有人可能会因为我说的话而笑，然后他们转过身去看别的东西。我突然想象成当他们转过身背对着我时，他们在做那种表情，翻着白眼，仿佛在说：“真是个白痴。”而且我开始注意到，当我在老师课上举手回答问题时，她脸上的表情仿佛是在忍受我。
You know what's so interesting about that is that the book made you act in a way which was completely phony and calculating. And so then the thought entered your head, maybe everybody else is acting phony and calculating as well.
你知道最有趣的是什么吗？是这本书让你表现得完全虚伪和算计。于是你脑子里就产生了这样的想法，也许其他人也都在虚伪和算计。
Yeah. It was almost like I had been given this sort of handbook to the human mind that I didn't want.
是的。这几乎就像我被赋予了一本我并不想要的人类心灵手册。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today on our program, How to Win Friends and Influence People. Stories of people climbing to be number one. How do they do it? What is the fundamental difference between us and them? We answer that question today in four simple lessons that will change your life forever. Or possibly won't.
今天我们的节目主题是《人性的弱点》。关于人们努力争做第一的故事。他们是怎么做到的？我们和他们之间最根本的区别是什么？我们今天将通过四个简单的课程来回答这个问题，这些课程将永远改变你的生活。或者可能根本不会。
Lesson one, To Make a Friend, Be a Friend. David Sedaris has an instructive tale of how as a boy, with the help of his dad, he tried to bridge the chasm that divides the popular kids from the unpopular. With pretty much exactly the sort of results that you might anticipate.
第一课：要交朋友，先做朋友。大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）有一个富有启发性的故事，讲述了他小时候如何在父亲的帮助下，试图跨越受欢迎的孩子与不受欢迎的孩子之间的鸿沟。结果正如你所预料的那样。
Lesson two, Stay in Touch. Yes, my friend, you can learn so many things about being a better friend, a better spouse, a better business person if you would simply imitate recent US diplomatic and foreign policy. Details in that lesson.
第二课：保持联系。是的，我的朋友，如果你能模仿近期的美国外交和对外政策，你就能学到很多关于成为更好的朋友、更好的配偶、更好的生意人的知识。本课将有详细内容。
Lesson three, People like You if You Put a Lot of Time into your Appearance. In that lesson, we hear the story of how a simple Superman custom changed one man's life for the better.
第三课：如果你在形象上投入大量时间，人们会喜欢你。在那一课里，我们将听到一个简单的超人装扮如何改变了一个人一生的故事。
Lesson four, Just be Yourself. Jonathan Goldstein demonstrates how to be bested by the most popular, most handsome, most powerful man in the world and not feel bad about it. Stay with us if you care about your future.
第四课：做你自己。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦（Jonathan Goldstein）将演示如何被世界上最受欢迎、最英俊、最强大的男人打败却不感到难过。如果你关心你的未来，请继续收听。
Lesson one, To Make a Friend, Be a Friend.
第一课：要交朋友，先做朋友。
Well, writer David Sedaris tell this story about the popular crowd and how easy it is to enter. This was recorded before a live audience. His story begins on Labor Day when David was a kid at the Raleigh Country Club in North Carolina.
作家大卫·塞达里斯讲述了这个关于广受欢迎的人群以及如何轻松融入其中的故事。这是在现场观众面前录制的。他的故事始于劳动节，那时大卫还是个孩子，在北卡罗来纳州的罗利乡村俱乐部。
I was in the snack bar listening to a group of sixth graders who lived in another part of town and sat discussing significant changes in their upcoming school year. According to the girl named Janet, neither Pam Dobbins nor JJ Jackson had been invited to the Fourth of July party hosted by the Pyle twins who later told Kimberly Matthews that both Pam and Mike were out of the picture as far as the seventh grade was concerned. Totally, completely out, Janet said. Poof.
我当时在小吃店，听一群住在城里另一边的六年级学生讨论他们即将到来的学年里的重要变化。据一个名叫珍妮特的女孩说，帕姆·多宾斯（Pam Dobbins）和JJ·杰克逊（JJ Jackson）都没有被邀请参加由派尔双胞胎（Pyle twins）举办的独立日派对，而这对双胞胎后来告诉金伯利·马修斯（Kimberly Matthews），就七年级而言，帕姆和迈克已经出局了。珍妮特说，完全彻底的出局了，砰的一声。
I didn't know any Pam Dobbins or JJ Jackson, but the reverential tone of Janet's voice sent me into a state of mild shock. Call me naive, but it had simply never occurred to me that other schools might have their own celebrity circles. At the age of 12, I thought the group at E.C. Brooks was, if not nationally known, then at least its own private phenomenon. Why else would our lives revolve around them? I, myself, was not a member of my school's popular crowd. But recall thinking that whoever they were, Janet's popular people couldn't begin to compete with ours. Then I worried that our popular crowd couldn't compare to those in Charlotte or Greensboro. Not to mention the thousands of schools located in other states.
我不认识什么帕姆·多宾斯或JJ·杰克逊，但珍妮特那种尊崇的语气让我感到轻微的震惊。说我天真也好，但我从未想到其他学校可能有他们自己的名流圈。12岁时，我认为我们学校那个群体，如果不是全国闻名，至少也是我们自己特有的现象。否则我们的生活怎么会围绕着他们转呢？我本人并不是学校受欢迎圈子里的一员，但我记得我当时想，无论他们是谁，珍妮特的那些受欢迎的人根本无法与我们学校的相比。然后我又担心，我们学校受欢迎的群体可能也比不上夏洛特或格林斯伯勒学校里的那些，更不用说其他州成千上万的学校了。
What if I'd wasted my entire life comparing myself to people who didn't really matter? Try as I might, I still can't wrap my mind around it.
如果我把一生都浪费在与那些其实无关紧要的人进行比较上，那该怎么办？尽管我努力去想，但我还是无法理解这一点。
They banded together in the third grade. Ann Carlsworth, Christie Kaymore, Deb Bevins, Mike Holliwell, Doug Middleton, Thad Pope. This was the core base of the popular crowd. And for the next six years, my classmates and I studied their lives the way we were supposed to study math and English. So complete was their power that I actually felt honored when one of them hit me in the mouth with a rock.
他们从三年级就开始结成团伙了。安·卡尔斯沃思（Ann Carlsworth）、克里斯蒂·凯莫尔（Christie Kaymore）、黛布·贝文斯（Deb Bevins）、迈克·霍利韦尔（Mike Holliwell）、道格·米德尔顿（Doug Middleton）、萨德·波普（Thad Pope）。这就是那个受欢迎群体核心成员。接下来的六年里，我和我的同学研究他们的生活，就像我们本该研究数学和英语一样。他们的影响力如此之大，以至于当其中一个人用石头打我的嘴时，我甚至感到很荣幸。
He'd gotten me after school, and upon returning home I ran into my sister's bedroom, hugging my bloody Kleenex and crying, it was Thad!
他在放学后堵住了我，回到家后，我冲进姐姐的卧室，抱着沾满血迹的纸巾哭着说：“是萨德！”
Lisa was a year older, but still she understood the significance.
丽莎（Lisa）比我大一岁，但她还是明白了其中的重要性。
Did he say anything, she asked. Did you save the rock?
“他说了什么吗？”她问。“你留着那块石头了吗？”
My father demanded that I retaliate, saying I ought to knock the guy on his ass.
我父亲要求我报复，说我应该把那家伙打得落花流水。
Oh, dad.
“噢，爸爸。”
Aww, baloney. Clock him on the snot locker and he'll go down like a ton of bricks.
“少废话。狠狠地往他的鼻子上打一拳，他就会像一吨砖头一样倒下。”
He was mistaking Thad for a bully, which was a different crowd altogether. Besides, who did my father think I was? Boys who spent their weekends making banana nut muffins did not, as a rule, excel in the art of hand-to-hand combat.
他把萨德误认为是欺凌者，那是完全不同的另一类群体。况且，我父亲以为我是谁？那些周末花时间做香蕉核桃松饼的男孩，通常情况下并不擅长近身肉搏的艺术。
I mean, come on, Dad, Lisa said. Wake up.
“得了吧，爸爸，”丽莎说，“清醒点吧。”
The following afternoon I was taken to Dr. Povlitch for x-rays. The rock had damaged a tooth and there was some question over who would pay for the subsequent root canal. I figured that since they'd conceive me, given birth, and raised me as a permanent guest in their home, my parents should foot the bill. But my father thought differently.
第二天下午，我被带到波弗里奇（Povlitch）医生那里拍X光片。石头损坏了一颗牙齿，关于谁来支付随后的根管治疗费产生了一些争议。我想，既然是父母生我、养我，并让我作为他们家里的永久客人，那么这笔费用应该由他们支付。但我父亲的想法不同。
He had decided the Popes should pay. And I screamed as he picked up the phone book, but you can't just call Thad's house.
他决定应该由波普家付钱。当他拿起电话簿时我尖叫起来，但你不能就这么给萨德家打电话。
Why the hell not. he said. Don't they have a telephone?
“为什么不能？”他说，“他们没有电话吗？”
Well, of course, the Popes had a telephone. Probably three or four with a separate line for the children. I imagined Thad's as a state of the art desk model with blinking red lights, alerting him that Doug or Christie was waiting on line one.
当然，波普家是有电话的。可能有三四台，孩子还有专线。我想象萨德的电话是那种带有闪烁红灯的顶级办公桌模型，提醒他道格或克里斯蒂正在一号线上等着他。
Equipment was not the issue. My father's voice simply did not belong on the Pope's telephone. It wouldn't fit with their things. A meeting was arranged for the following evening. And before leaving the house, I begged my father to change his clothes. He'd been building an addition to the carport and wore a pair of khaki shorts, smeared with paint and spotted here and there with bits of dried concrete. Through a hole in his tattered t-shirt, without squinting, it was possible to see his nipple.
设备不是问题。我父亲的声音根本不应该出现在波普家的电话里。这和他们的东西格格不入。于是安排在第二天晚上见面。在离开家之前，我求我父亲换身衣服。他一直在扩建车棚，穿着一条卡其短裤，上面沾满了油漆，到处都是干水泥斑点。透过他破旧T恤上的洞，不需眯眼就能看见他的乳头。
What the hell is wrong with this, he asked. We're not staying for dinner, so what does it matter?
“这到底有什么问题？”他问，“我们又不留下来吃晚饭，这有什么关系吗？”
I yelled for my mother, and in the end he compromised by changing his shirt.
我叫我妈过来，最后他妥协了，换了一件衬衫。
From the outside, Thad's house didn't look much different than anyone else's. Just a standard split level with what my father described as a totally inadequate carport. Mr. pope answered the door in a pair of sherbert-colored golf pants and led us downstairs into what he called the rumpus room.
从外面看，萨德的房子和别人的房子没什么两样。只是一个标准的错层式住宅，带有一个我父亲形容为完全不合格的车棚。波普先生穿着一条雪芭色（sherbert-colored）的高尔夫球裤开了门，领着我们走下楼梯，进入了他所谓的“喧闹室”（rumpus room）。
Oh, I said. This is nice. The room was damp and windowless and lit with hanging Tiffany lamp shades. The shards of colorful glass arranged to spell the words Busch and Budweiser. Walls were paneled and the furniture looked as though it had been hand-hewn by settlers who had reconfigured parts of their beloved Conestoga wagon to fashion such things as easy chairs and coffee tables.
“噢，”我说，“这儿真不错。”房间潮湿、没有窗户，挂着蒂芙尼灯罩，彩色玻璃碎片拼成了“Busch”和“Budweiser”这两个词。墙壁上有镶板，家具看起来像是被那些重新利用了他们心爱的康内斯托加马车零件的拓荒者亲手打造的，用来制作摇椅和咖啡桌等东西。
He directed us towards a sofa and asked if we wanted anything to drink. Coke? A beer? I didn't want to deplete Thad's precious cola supply, but before I could refuse my father said, sure. We'd have one of each. The orders were called up the stairway and a few minutes later Mrs. pope entered the room, carrying cans and plastic tumblers. And as she set the drinks before us, I noticed that her son had inherited her blunt, slightly upturned nose. Which looked good on him, but caused her to appear overly suspicious and judgmental.
他把我们引向沙发，问我们要不要喝点什么。可乐？啤酒？我不想喝掉萨德宝贵的可乐储备，但还没等我拒绝，我父亲就说：“当然，每样来一份。”订单通过楼梯呼喊上去，几分钟后，波普太太进屋了，端着罐装饮料和塑料杯。当她把饮料放在我们面前时，我注意到她的儿子遗传了她那种钝的、微微上翘的鼻子。这对萨德来说看起来不错，但让她显得过于多疑和挑剔。
So, she said, I hear you've been to the dentist. She was just trying to make small talk, but due to or nose it came off sounding like an insult. As if I'd just had a tooth filled and was now looking for someone to pay the bill.
“那么，”她说，“听说你去看牙医了。”她只是想闲聊，但由于她的鼻子，这话听起来像是一种侮辱。好像我刚补好牙，现在正想找人付钱。
I'll say he's been to the dentist, my father said. Someone hits you in the mouth with a rock, and I'd say the dentist's office is pretty much the first place a reasonable person would go.
“我可以肯定他是去看牙医了，”我父亲说，“有人用石头打了你的嘴，我会说牙医办公室大概是任何理智的人最先去的地方。”
Mr. Pope held up his hands. Whoa now, he said. Let's just calm things down a little.
波普先生举起双手，“好啦，”他说，“让我们冷静一下。”
He yelled upstairs for his son. And when there was no answer he picked up the phone, telling Thad to stop running his mouth and get his butt down to the rumpus room ASAP.
他对着楼上喊他的儿子。没有回应，于是他拿起电话，告诉萨德别再胡说八道了，立刻把屁股挪到喧闹室来。
A rush of footsteps on the carpeted staircase and then Thad sprinted in, all smiles and apologies. The minister had called. The game had been rescheduled. Hello, sir. And you are?
铺着地毯的楼梯上传来一阵匆忙的脚步声，接着萨德跑了进来，满脸笑容，满口道歉。说是牧师打电话来了，比赛改期了。“您好，先生。您是？”
He looked my father in the eye and firmly shook his hand, holding it in his own for just the right amount of time. With others our age, the gesture appeared forced and sloppy, but Thad seemed born to it. While most handshakes mumbled, his clearly spoke. Saying both, we'll get through this and I'm looking forward to your vote this coming November.
他直视我父亲的眼睛，坚定地握了握他的手，保持了恰到好处的时间。对于我们同龄的其他人来说，这个姿势显得被迫且草率，但萨德似乎天生就会这一套。虽然大多数握手含糊不清，但他的握手显然在说话。仿佛在说：“我们能解决这个问题，而且我期待在今年十一月投您一票。”
I'd thought that seeing him without his group might be unsettling, like finding a single arm on the sidewalk. But Thad was fully capable of operating independently. Watching him in action I understood that his popularity was not an accident. Unlike a normal human, he possessed an uncanny and wholly natural ability to please people. Much like a Whitman's Sampler, he seemed to offer a little bit of everything. Pass on his athletic ability and you might partake of his excellent manners, his confidence, his coltish enthusiasm. Even his parents seemed invigorated by his presence.
我曾想过在没有他那一帮人的情况下见到他可能会让人不安，就像在人行道上发现一只孤零零的手臂一样。但萨德完全有能力独立行事。看着他的表演，我明白他的受欢迎绝非偶然。不像普通人，他拥有一种不可思议且完全自然的能力来取悦他人。就像一盒惠特曼巧克力，他似乎什么都能提供一点。忽视他那运动能力，你可能会领略到他极好的礼貌、他的自信、他那小马般的热情。甚至他的父母似乎也因为他的存在而精神焕发。
All right, then, Mr. Pope said. Now that everyone's accounted for, I'm hoping we can clear this up. Sticks and stones aside, I suspect this all comes down to a little misunderstanding between friends.
“好了，”波普先生说，“既然人都到齐了，我希望我们能把这件事解决。抛开棍棒和石头不谈，我怀疑这归根结底是朋友之间的小误会。”
I lowered my eyes, waiting for Thad to set his father straight. Friends, with him? I expected laughter or the famous Thad snort. But instead he said nothing. And with his silence, he won me completely. A little misunderstanding. That's exactly what it was.
我低下头，等着萨德反驳他父亲。和他做朋友？我期待着大笑或者萨德那著名的响鼻声。但他什么也没说。通过他的沉默，他彻底赢得了我。一个小误会。确实就是这样。
The immediate goal was to save my friend. And so I claimed to have essentially thrown myself in the path of Thad's fast-moving rock.
眼前的目标是拯救我的朋友。所以我声称我基本上是自己冲到了萨德那块飞速飞行的石头路径上。
What the hell was he throwing rocks for, my father asked. What the hell was he throwing them at?
“他到底为什么要扔石头？”我父亲问，“他到底在扔什么？”
Mrs. Pope frowned, implying that such language was not welcome in the rumpus room. I mean, Jesus Christ, the guy's got to be a complete idiot.
波普太太皱起眉头，暗示这种语言在喧闹室里是不受欢迎的，“我是说，天哪，那家伙肯定是个十足的傻瓜。”
Thad swore he hadn't been aiming at anything and I backed him up, saying it was just one of those things we all did. Like in Vietnam, or whatever. It was just friendly fire.
萨德发誓他没有瞄准任何东西，我支持他，说这只是我们都会做的那种事。就像在越南发生的那种事，什么的。这只是友军误伤。
My father asked what the hell I knew about Vietnam. And again, Thad's mother winced, saying that boys picked up a lot of this talk by watching the news.
我父亲问我对越南到底知道些什么。萨德的母亲又畏缩了一下，说男孩们看了新闻就会学到很多这种谈话。
Oh, you don't know what you're talking about, my father said.
“噢，你根本不知道你在说什么，”我父亲说。
What my wife meant, Mr. Pope said.
“我太太的意思是……”波普先生说。
Ah, baloney. The trio of Popes exchanged meaningful glances, holding what amounted to a brief telepathic powwow.
“少废话。”三个波普一家交换了意味深长的眼神，进行了一场简短的心灵感应交流。
This man crazy, the smoke signals read.
烟雾信号显示：这个男人疯了。
I looked at my father then, a man in dirty shorts who drank his beer from the can rather than pouring it into his tumbler. And I thought, you don't belong here. More precisely I decided that he was the reason I didn't belong.
那时我看着我的父亲，一个穿着脏短裤、从罐子里直接喝啤酒而不是倒进杯子里的男人。我想，你不属于这里。更准确地说，我认定他就是我不属于这里的原因。
How was a person expected to fit in when he'd been steadily poisoned by his parents? Fed little doses until he was ultimately so contaminated that no one would have anything to do with him. The hokey Greek phrases, the how-to lectures on mixing your own concrete. The squabble over who would pay the stupid dentist bill. Little by little, it had all seeped into my bloodstream, robbing me of my natural ability to please others.
当一个人一直被父母荼毒时，怎么能指望他融入社会呢？一点一点地喂食，直到最终被彻底污染，以至于没有人愿意和他有任何瓜葛。那些老掉牙的希腊短语，关于调配混凝土的“操作指南”演讲。关于谁来支付那笔愚蠢的牙医费用的争吵。一点一点地，这一切都渗透进了我的血液，剥夺了我取悦他人的本能。
Well, Mr. pope said, I can see that this is going nowhere.
“好吧，”波普先生说，“我看这事没完没了了。”
My father laughed saying, yeah, you got that right. It sounded like a parting sentence, but rather then standing to leave, he leaned back on the sofa and rested his beer can upon his stomach. We're all going nowhere.
我父亲大笑着说：“是啊，你说对了。”这听起来像是一句离别的话，但他没有站起来离开，而是向后靠在沙发上，把啤酒罐放在肚子上。“我们谁也没处可去。”
At this point, I was pretty sure that Thad and I were envisioning the same grim scenario. While the rest of the world would move on, in a year's time my filthy, bearded father would still be occupying the rumpus room sofa.
在这一点上，我相当确定萨德和我正设想着同样严峻的场景。当世界上的其他人继续前进时，一年后，我那肮脏、满脸胡渣的父亲可能仍然会占据着喧闹室的沙发。
Christmas would come, friends would visit, and the Popes would bitterly direct them towards one of the easy chairs. Just ignore him, they'd say. He'll go home sooner or later.
圣诞节会到来，朋友们会来访，波普一家会气愤地把他们引向其中一把摇椅。“别管他，”他们会说，“他迟早会回家的。”
In the end, they agreed to pay for half the root canal. Not because they thought it was fair, but because they wanted us out of their house.
最后，他们同意支付一半的根管治疗费。不是因为他们认为这很公平，而是因为他们想让我们离开他们的房子。
Some friendships are formed by a commonality of interests and ideas. You both love judo or camping or making your own sausage. Other friendships are forged by a mutual hatred of a common enemy. On leaving Thad's house, I decided that ours would probably be the latter.
有些友谊是由共同的兴趣和想法形成的。你们都喜欢柔道、露营或自制香肠。有些友谊是由对共同敌人的共同仇恨所锻造的。离开萨德家时，我认定我们的友谊很可能是后者。
We'd start off grousing about my father, maybe going so far as to scratch up his car. And then, little by little, we'd move on to the hundreds of other things and people that got on our nerves.
我们会从抱怨我父亲开始，也许会发展到去划花他的车。然后，一点一点地，我们会转向数百种其他让我们心烦的事物和人。
You hate olives, I imagined him saying. I hate them too.
“你讨厌橄榄，”我想象他说，“我也讨厌它们。”
As it turned out, the one thing we both hated was me. Rather, I hated me. Thad couldn't even work up the enthusiasm.
事实证明，我们唯一都讨厌的东西就是我。确切地说，我讨厌我自己。萨德甚至都提不起劲来讨厌我。
The day after the meeting I approached him in the lunchroom where he sat as his regular table surrounded by his regular friends.
会议结束后的第二天，我在餐厅靠近他，他坐在常坐的餐桌旁，被他常有的朋友包围着。
Listen, I said. I am really sorry about that stuff with my dad. I'd worked up a whole long speech, complete with imitations. But by the time I hit my second sentence he turned to resume his conversation with Doug Middleton. I've heard your testimony, my father's behavior, even the rock throwing. I was so far beneath him that it hadn't even registered. Poof.
“听着，”我说，“我真的很抱歉关于我父亲的那些事。”我已经准备好了一大段长篇大论，甚至配上了模仿表演。但在我说到第二句时，他转过身继续和道格·米德尔顿聊天。我听到了你的证词，我父亲的行为，甚至扔石头的事。我对他来说实在太卑微了，以至于他根本没注意到我。砰的一声。
The socialites of E.C. Brooks shown even brighter in junior high. But come 10th grade, things began to change. Desegregation drove a lot of the popular people into private schools. And those who remained seemed silly and archaic, deposed royalty from a country the average citizen had ceased to care about.
E.C. 布鲁克斯高中的名流们在初中时表现得更加耀眼。但到了十年级，情况开始发生变化。种族融合将许多受欢迎的人赶进了私立学校。而留下来的人似乎既愚蠢又陈旧，就像一个普通公民不再关心的国家的被废黜的皇室成员。
Early in our junior year, Thad was jumped by a group of the new black kids who yanked off his shoes and threw them in the toilet. I knew I was supposed to be happy, but part of me felt personally assaulted.
在我们高二那年年初，萨德被一群新来的黑人孩子围攻，他们脱掉了他的鞋子，扔进了厕所。我知道我本该感到高兴，但内心的一部分却感到像是自己受到了人身攻击。
Yes, he'd been a negligent prince, yet I still believed in the monarchy.
是的，他曾是一位玩忽职守的王子，但我依然相信君主制。
When his name was called at graduation, it was me who clapped the longest. Outlasting even his parents who politely stopped once he'd left the stage.
当他在毕业典礼上被叫到名字时，我是鼓掌时间最长的人。甚至超过了他的父母，他们在萨德离开舞台后礼貌地停止了鼓掌。
I thought about that a lot over the coming years. He's the poet laureate of Liechtenstein, the surgeon who cures cancer with love. The ninth grade teacher who insists that the world is big enough for everyone.
在随后的岁月里，我经常想到这一点。他是列支敦士登的桂冠诗人，是用爱治愈癌症的外科医生。是那位坚持认为世界足够大的九年级老师。
When moving to another city I'm always hoping to find him living in the apartment next door. We'll meet in the hallway and he'll stick out his hand saying, excuse me, but don't I-- shouldn't I know you? It doesn't have to happen today, but it does have to happen. I've kept a space waiting for him. And if he doesn't show up I'll have to forgive my father.
搬到另一个城市时，我总是希望能发现他住在隔壁公寓。我们会在走廊里相遇，他会伸出手说：“对不起，难道我不——难道我不该认识你吗？”这不一定要今天发生，但它必须发生。我一直为他留着一个位置。如果他没有出现，我就必须原谅我的父亲。
David Sedaris, recorded at the Detroit Institute of Art by WDET. His new book is called When You Are Engulfed in Flames.
大卫·塞达里斯，由WDET电台在底特律艺术学院录制。他的新书名为《当你陷入火焰中》（When You Are Engulfed in Flames）。
Coming up, it's OK if you're not Superman. Unless, of course, your girlfriend used to date Superman. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如果你不是超人也没关系。当然，除非你的女朋友曾经和超人约会过。稍后我们将从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we chose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, How to Win Friends and Influence People. We have four lessons on the subject. We have arrived at lesson two, Stay in Touch.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的相关故事。今天的节目主题是《人性的弱点》。我们有四个关于该主题的课程。现在我们来到了第二课：保持联系。
Since September 11, the United States of America has faced some special challenges in trying to win friends and influence people among the world's nations. There was the whole attempt to rally countries at the United Nations against Saddam Hussein. And then after that, to convince other nations to join us in a war against Iraq. But it was delicate even before all that.
自9月11日以来，美利坚合众国在试图在世界各国中赢得朋友和影响他人时面临了一些特殊挑战。曾经有在联合国召集各国反对萨达姆·侯赛因的整个尝试。然后在那之后，说服其他国家加入我们的对伊拉克战争。但即使在这一切之前，情况就很微妙。
From the very beginning of the war on terror, when US diplomats had to start working the phones to assemble a coalition of nations to begin to combat this new threat. Some of the calls you get the feeling, were not the easiest kinds of phone calls to make. Countries that were mad at us for one reason or another. Countries that we'd acted all interested in for a while in the past and then just kind of stopped calling. Back in late 2001, you may remember you kept seeing Secretary of State Colin Powell in the paper saying things like our sudden new interest in Pakistan wasn't quote, "Just a temporary spike in American interest." That we had quote, "An enduring commitment." And that Pakistan was quote, "A great Muslim nation."
从反恐战争一开始，当美国外交官不得不开始拨打电话召集一个国家联盟来开始打击这种新威胁时，你会有种感觉，有些电话不是那么容易拨打的。那些因为某种原因生我们气的国家。那些我们在过去一段时间里表现得很有兴趣，然后就不再打电话的国家。回到2001年底，你可能还记得你不断在报纸上看到国务卿科林·鲍威尔（Colin Powell）说这样的话：我们对巴基斯坦突然产生的新兴趣并非所谓的“美国兴趣的暂时激增”。我们有所谓的“持久承诺”。而且巴基斯坦是一个所谓的“伟大的穆斯林国家”。
What where those first phone calls like? Well, all the way back in 2001, one of our contributors, Tami Sagher, tried to imagine exactly that.
那些最初的电话打起来是什么样的？嗯，早在2001年，我们的一位撰稿人塔米·萨格（Tami Sagher）试图想象那具体的情景。
Hi. Pakistan? Hi, it's America. How are you? Oh my God. I almost didn't recognize your voice. It's been so long.
“嘿。巴基斯坦吗？嘿，我是美国。你好吗？天哪。我差点没认出你的声音。好久没联系了。”
Listen, I was just getting together this little coalition and I was like, who have I have not seen? Pakistan. Oh, yeah. Well, how are you? How's Kashmir? That's yours, right?
“听着，我刚凑齐了一个小联盟，我就想，我好久没见到谁了？巴基斯坦。噢，对了。嗯，你好吗？克什米尔怎么样？那是你们的，对吧？”
Oh, you're kidding me. Now when I think of Kashmir, I think it's yours. Just straight out, Pakistani Kashmir. Oh, God.
“噢，你在开玩笑吧。当我想到克什米尔时，我以为是你们的。就直接说是巴基斯坦的克什米尔。噢，天哪。”
Well, we will see you at the coalition then.
“好吧，那我们在联盟见吧。”
Oh, God. I can't believe I forgot this. Also wondering maybe if you could bring along some full exchange of intelligence and use of ports. No big deal if you forget. But if you do, that would be great. All right, see you soon.
“噢，天哪。我真不敢相信我忘了这个。还在想也许你能带上一些全面的情报交流和港口使用权。如果你忘了也没什么大不了的。但如果你能做到，那太棒了。好了，回头见。”
India, it's America.
“印度，我是美国。”
Yes. You remember. Hi.
“是的。你还记得。嘿。”
No, I have been thinking about calling you, like every night I was like, got to call India. But you know the time difference.
“不，我一直在想给你打电话，每天晚上我都在想，得给印度打个电话。但你知道时差嘛。”
Oh, how are you? How's Kashmir?
“噢，你好吗？克什米尔怎么样？”
You're kidding. No, come on. That's yours, isn't it?
“你在开玩笑吧。不，别这样。那是你们的，不是吗？”
So how are you?
“那你最近怎么样？”
Listen, getting together a little coalish. Wondering if you'd be up to join.
“听着，正在筹备一个小联盟。想问问你是否有兴趣参加。”
Paka-who? Pakistan. No, I didn't even think of calling them.
“巴基谁？巴基斯坦。不，我根本没想过要给他们打电话。”
Well, do you want me to because I will.
“好吧，你要我打吗？因为我会打的。”
Well, I don't know. I don't care. This is about you, India. Yes, it is. OK. OK, well see you real soon. Love you. Is that weird to say? It doesn't feel weird. OK, bye.
“嗯，我不知道。我不在乎。这是关于你的，印度。是的，就是这样。好吧。好吧，回头见。爱你。那样说很奇怪吗？感觉不奇怪。好吧，再见。”
Hello, may I please speak to Iran?
“喂，我可以和伊朗通话吗？”
Hi, it's America. The United States of America. Hi.
“嘿，我是美国。美利坚合众国。嘿。”
Yeah, God, it feels so weird to talk to you again. I know we haven't talked. God, since the hostage crisis. Well, you know it was one of those things where it was just easier to just stay away and just sort of repair myself a little bit. And I just figured you were in the same place.
“是的，天哪，再次和你通话感觉真奇怪。我知道我们没联系过。天哪，自从人质危机以来。嗯，你知道那是那种最好保持距离，顺便稍微自我修复一下的情况。我还以为你也处于同样的状态。”
If you need anything, any money, or anything, you just call and maybe I'll see you. Maybe I'll fly overhead in your air space. Don't freak out if I do. All right. Talk to you soon. Bye.
“如果你需要什么，钱之类的，只要你打个电话，也许我会见你。也许我会飞越你的领空。如果我这么做了，别惊慌。好了。回头聊。再见。”
Hello, China? Hi, it's America. Hi. I am-- this is hard. I wanted to apologize.
“喂，中国吗？嘿，我是美国。嘿。我——这很难。我想道歉。”
About the plane, yes. I'm so sorry. Yeah, and about the embassy, it blew up. And about that fishing boat.
“关于那架飞机，是的。我很抱歉。是的，还有大使馆的事，它炸了。还有那艘渔船。”
Oh my God. You're right, it was Japan. I'm so-- ah. No, you do not look alike. I'm sorry. No, that is me being a big fat jerk. I am so sorry. Well now I feel like twice a jerk.
“噢，天哪。你是对的，那是日本。我很——啊。不，你们看起来不像。我很抱歉。不，那是我在做一个大胖傻瓜。我很抱歉。好吧，现在我觉得自己像个双倍的傻瓜。”
Listen, I am getting together a coalition and wondering if you'd be up for it.
“听着，我正在筹备一个联盟，想问问你是否有兴趣参加。”
Oh, good. I know you share a border with Afghanistan, so I don't want that to be weird because I'm not inviting them. But if you could come that would be great.
“噢，太好了。我知道你和阿富汗接壤，所以我不希望这变得尴尬，因为我没有邀请他们。但如果你能来，那太棒了。”
OK, really look forward to seeing you. You know what? I bet in an hour I'm going to want to call you again. That's a terrible joke. I know I make it every time. OK, I'll talk to you soon. Bye.
“好吧，真的很期待见到你。你知道吗？我打赌过一会儿我又会想给你打电话。那是个糟糕的笑话。我知道我每次都讲这个。好吧，回头聊。再见。”
Tami Sagher, formerly of Chicago's Second City. She's now a writer on the TV show 30 Rock.
塔米·萨格，前芝加哥第二城市剧团成员。她现在是电视剧《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）的编剧。
[MUSIC- "THIS IS THE WORLD CALLING" BY BOB GELDOF]
[音乐- 鲍勃·格尔多夫（Bob Geldof）的《这是世界在呼唤》]
Lesson three, People Like You if You Put a lot of Time into your Appearance.
第三课：如果你在形象上投入大量时间，人们会喜欢你。
To prove this simple point-- a familiar one to readers of any women's magazines-- we have this true story of moral instruction told by Luke Burbank in Seattle.
为了证明这个简单的道理——这对于任何女性杂志的读者来说都很熟悉——我们有这个由卢克·伯班克（Luke Burbank）在西雅图讲述的道德教育真实故事。
I was in the Las Vegas Airport when I noticed this guy dressed like Superman. I'm talking red boots, blue Spandex leggings, a yellow belt, a big S on his chest. And of course, a long, red cape.
我在拉斯维加斯机场时，注意到这个装扮成超人的家伙。我说的是红靴子、蓝色弹力紧身裤、黄腰带、胸前有个大S。当然，还有一件长长的红斗篷。
I was struck by how authentic the outfit was, and the fact that he didn't have any baggage. No suitcase, no backpack, no wallet, no keys. He looked calm and happy and sort of out of place.
令我惊讶的是这套衣服是多么逼真，而且他居然没有带任何行李。没有手提箱，没有背包，没有钱包，没有钥匙。他看起来冷静、快乐，而且有点格格不入。
Since I was in Las Vegas, I figured he was some performer from one of the casinos who was running late and didn't have time to change or something. I didn't think too much more about him until I was getting on the plane. I noticed that there was much more excitement in the air than I'm used to on a flight home from Las Vegas. They were talking about this guy dressed as Superman.
因为我在拉斯维加斯，所以我以为他是某个赌场迟到的表演者，来不及换装之类的。直到我登机，我都没再多想他。我注意到机舱内的兴奋气氛比我平时乘坐拉斯维加斯回程航班时要高得多。大家都在谈论这个打扮成超人的家伙。
Turns out he was sitting right behind me. At one point, the co-pilot got on the intercom and announced that Superman's hotel had called. And that he'd left his Pokemon pajamas in his room and that they wanted to know where to send them. Everyone cracked up, including me. But Superman didn't say anything, he just sat there with a slight smile on his face.
结果他就坐在我后面。机长通过广播宣布超人的酒店打了电话。说他把宝可梦（Pokemon）睡衣忘在房间里了，他们想知道该寄到哪里去。大家都笑翻了，包括我。但超人什么也没说，只是坐在那里，脸上带着淡淡的微笑。
During the flight, a steady stream of guys on their way to the bathroom would ask, hey, Superman, what do you need the plane for? Women tended to ask why he had the costume on.
飞行过程中，那些去洗手间的家伙们会不断地问：“嘿，超人，你为什么还要坐飞机？”女性则倾向于问他为什么穿着这身戏服。
Generally, he kept his answers short and polite. He didn't parade around the plane or call extra attention to himself. And I remember thinking that he seemed pretty normal for a guy in a Superman costume.
通常，他的回答简短而礼貌。他没有在飞机上四处游荡，也没有吸引过多的注意力。我记得当时我想，对于一个穿着超人戏服的家伙来说，他看起来相当正常。
My friends and I came up with a theory that he'd lost a bet, so when the plane stopped over in San Jose, I decided to talk to him. His real name is Mark Wyzenbeek. I met with him a week later at his condo in Auburn, Washington, a suburb about 20 minutes south of Seattle.
我和朋友们推测他是不是打赌输了，所以当飞机在圣何塞经停时，我决定和他谈谈。他真名叫马克·怀森贝克（Mark Wyzenbeek）。一周后我在奥本（Auburn）的一家公寓里见到了他，那是西雅图以南约20分钟路程的一个郊区。
He wasn't wearing the costume when I showed up, and I asked him how often he actually did.
我出现时他没穿那套衣服，我问他平时到底多久穿一次。
Every weekend I get a chance to put it on, I'll put it on. Every day that I don't have too much scheduled, I'll pop it on. A lot of times I can't wait to pop it on because you know as soon as someone sees you, their day is different. They've got a story to tell. And it's something that they're always going to remember.
“每个周末我有机会穿它，我就会穿上。每一天如果我没有太多行程，我就穿上。很多时候我迫不及待地想穿上它，因为你知道一旦有人看到你，他们的一天就不同了。他们会有个故事可以讲。这是他们永远会记得的事情。”
And I'll guarantee you the pilot on that flight that we were on is still talking about this. That he had Superman on his plane.
“我敢保证，我们乘坐那次航班的飞行员现在还在谈论这件事。他那次航班上有超人。”
Yeah, by the way, that didn't get on your nerves when they said that thing about your Pokemon pajamas?
“顺便问一下，当他们说你宝可梦睡衣的事时，你没感到恼火吗？”
No. You get used to it. And I don't see it as a cut, but more a compliment that they even mentioned to the whole plane that Superman was on their flight.
“没有。你习惯了。我不觉得那是嘲讽，而更多是一种恭维，因为他们甚至向全机的人提到了超人在他们的航班上。”
His two bedroom apartment is filled, and I mean filled, with Superman memorabilia. Superman dishes, Superman sheets on the bed, a Superman mouse pad, golf tees, paper clips, you name it.
他的两居室公寓里装满了，我说的是装满了超人纪念品。超人餐具、床上的超人床单、超人鼠标垫、高尔夫球钉、回形针，应有尽有。
In the living room, just to the right of the TV hang five Superman costume side by side. Then there are the Batman masks, probably eight of them, sitting on dummy heads. It feels like a locker room for superheroes.
在客厅里，电视机右边挂着五套超人戏服并排排开。旁边还有蝙蝠侠面具，大概有八个，戴在假人头上。感觉就像超级英雄的更衣室。
He started dressing as Superman two years ago after his wife died in a car accident.
他在妻子车祸去世后，两年前开始打扮成超人。
I had never had anyone real close to me pass away before. Your grandparents, they've lived a full life and you're expecting that. But someone so young and beautiful and with their whole life ahead of them, it just really hit me that she doesn't have any more tomorrows. And I thought, well, I better start getting as much out of today-- each today-- as I can.
“我以前从未经历过亲近的人去世。你的祖父母，他们度过了充实的一生，你会有所预料。但一个如此年轻漂亮、前程似锦的人，真的让我深受打击，意识到她再也没有明天了。我想，好吧，我最好在今天——每一个今天——中尽可能多地去感受。”
And what would help me do that? And I enjoy wearing the costumes. And I just couldn't wait to go out somewhere and have a bunch of people see it. And it's just been a real kick ever since.
“什么能帮我做到这一点呢？我很享受穿上这些服装。我迫不及待地想去某个地方，让一群人看到它。从那以后，这真的给我带来了很大的刺激。”
Do you remember the first time you wore it out in public? What was that like?
你还记得第一次在公共场合穿它吗？那是什么样的感觉？
When I completed my first costume, I had to go down, put some gas in the car. And I climbed out of the car, and I'm putting the fuel in. And the cars pulling up to the signal were going nuts. And I knew right then that I'm onto something. This is going to be a lot of fun.
当我完成第一套戏服时，我必须开车去加油。我从车里爬出来，正在加油。等红灯的车里的人都疯了。就在那一刻我知道我走对路了。这会非常有趣。
And the neat thing is, is when they honk at you, they're all looking and you hear this talk in the car. Oh, look. There's Superman. There's Superman. And the neat thing is, is they won't stop honking until you look at them. They have to have that eye contact with you knowing that they're looking at you and that you see them looking at you. And then the whole cycle's complete, and then everyone's having a good time.
“最棒的是，当他们对你按喇叭时，他们都在看，你听见车里在议论。‘噢，快看。那是超人。那是超人。’而且最棒的是，除非你看他们，否则他们不会停止按喇叭。他们必须和你进行那种眼神交流，知道他们在看你，而且你知道他们在看着你。然后整个循环就完整了，大家都玩得很开心。”
Mark had always been a collector of Superman stuff. But after his wife died he decided to go for broke and spend most of his money on an original costume from the TV show Superboy. He's only tried that costume on once, and it's too special to wear outside. Instead, he taught himself how to sew and started making his own Superman outfits. Which frankly, I thought were better looking than the one he bought.
马克一直是个超人产品收藏家。但在妻子去世后，他决定孤注一掷，把他大部分钱都花在了电视剧《少年超人》（Superboy）的一套原始戏服上。那套衣服他只试穿过一次，太珍贵了，不能穿到外面去。相反，他自学了缝纫，开始制作自己的超人服装。坦率地说，我觉得比他买的那套更好看。
Mark also owns a Batman costume that George Clooney actually wore in the Batman movie. He wears Superman in the summer and Batman in the winter. The Batman outfit is made of foam rubber and is warmer, which he needs because he doesn't like to cover the costume with a coat when he goes outside.
马克还有一套乔治·克鲁尼（George Clooney）在蝙蝠侠电影中穿过的蝙蝠侠服装。他夏天穿超人装，冬天穿蝙蝠侠装。蝙蝠侠服装是泡沫橡胶做的，更暖和，这对他来说很有必要，因为他不希望出门时在戏服外面再穿一件外套。
Here's the Superboy costume as seen on TV by millions, worn by Gerard Christopher. He took over the show in the second year through the fourth year. They had a different actor do it the very first year.
这就是电视上数百万观众看到的《少年超人》服装，由杰拉德·克里斯托弗（Gerard Christopher）穿着。他在第二年到第四年接管了这部剧。第一年有另一位演员扮演。
But as you can see, the seam along most of the yellow here is hidden except for these three areas. And like a--
但正如你所看到的，黄色边缘的大部分缝线都被隐藏了，除了这三个区域。就像一个——
Mark's attention to detail when it comes to his outfits is incredible. He says that authenticity is the key to being taken seriously.
马克对戏服细节的关注令人难以置信。他说真实性是被人认真对待的关键。
If it wasn't 100%, then I would be letting down the costume. I'd be letting down the people looking at it. You can get your little $40 Halloween costume ones that are great for the office party. And that's fine. But to go out in public, unless you look like you're right off of the movie screen, then I don't suggest that you do it. Because you'll be a joke then.
“如果不是100%，那么我就辜负了这套戏服。我就辜负了看它的人。你可以买那种40美元的万圣节服装，适合办公室派对。那很好。但要在公共场合，除非你看上去就像直接从电影屏幕上走下来，否则我不建议你这样做。因为那样你就会变成一个笑话。”
Have you replaced your wife, or the void that your wife's passing left? Have you replaced that a little bit with your pursuit of this Superman and Batman stuff?
你是否用这种追求超人和蝙蝠侠的行为，稍微填补了妻子离去留下的空白或缺失？
It definitely takes your mind off of it. Any kind of a diversion or activity instead of thinking about things that you've lost is always a plus.
“这绝对能让你转移注意力。任何形式的消遣或活动，而不是去想那些你已经失去的东西，总是一件好事。”
The costumes, to be able to wear those in public, I don't know exactly how she would have taken it. I miss her a lot. I think of her every day. But the way I think of her now is that I just have a feeling that she's out there and that she's helping with this.
“这些服装，能在公共场合穿它们，我不知道她会怎么看。我很想念她。我每天都想起她。但我现在对她的想法是，我只是有一种感觉，觉得她在某处，并且她在帮助我做这件事。”
Two or three times a week Mark goes to bars in costume. I asked if I could go with him to see for myself. He suits up and we climb into his car, a white 1992 Pontiac Grand Prix with customized Superman plates.
每周两三次，马克会穿着戏服去酒吧。我问他我能不能和他一起去看看。他换好衣服，我们钻进他的车，一辆白色的1992年庞蒂亚克大奖赛（Pontiac Grand Prix），挂着定制的超人车牌。
We'll just hop in the Superman mobile here, as you can see, by my license plate.
“我们要跳进这辆超人手机里了，如你所见，看我的车牌。”
So you've got the Supermen floor mats.
所以你有超人地垫。
Floor mats. I got the neat little hanging, flying thing here. A nice little custom logo on my steering wheel.
“地垫。我还有这个漂亮的小挂件，飞行的那个。方向盘上有一个不错的自定义标志。”
Now I noticed you put down a t-shirt. Is that so your boots don't get scuff?
我注意到你铺了一件T恤。是为了不磨损你的靴子吗？
Yeah, I just don't want to scuff the back of the heel there.
“是的，我只是不想磨损鞋跟后面。”
I was going to get a 'Vette but then for my work I needed a backseat. I thought, well, I'll just get something that's spunky and corners and accelerates and something that's fun.
“我本来想买辆克尔维特（'Vette），但因为工作需要后座。我想，好吧，我就买辆时髦、转弯加速快、好玩的东西。”
So where do you figure Superman wants to go on a night like tonight?
你觉得超人在这样的夜晚想去哪儿？
Geez, on a Monday night. Gosh. We could head down to a couple of local places here. I don't know how busy they're going to be.
“天哪，周一晚上。哎呀。我们可以去几个本地的地方。我不知道会挤成什么样。”
Auburn, where Mark lives, is not exactly a hotbed of nighttime activity. Its claim to fame is that you drive through it to get to the area's only Ikea. At night, your options are fast food or a sports bar. We go to a sports bar.
马克居住的奥本，并不是什么夜生活中心。它的成名之处在于你必须开车穿过它才能到达该地区唯一的宜家。晚上，你的选择是快餐店或体育酒吧。我们去了体育酒吧。
As we got closer, I started to get nervous. I worried we were going to get laughed right out of the place. Mark and I were like anti-superheroes. He, a grown man dressed as Superman. Me, a grown man following him around with headphones and a shotgun microphone. He was like super geek and I was his geek protege.
当我们走近时，我开始感到紧张。我担心我们会被人嘲笑出局。马克和我就像反超级英雄。他，一个穿着超人装的成年男人。我，一个戴着耳机、拿着枪式麦克风跟着他的成年男人。他就像超级书呆子，而我是他的书呆子门徒。
We pulled up to the Sports Page Pub. Mark was excited. I was worried.
我们把车停在“体育报”酒吧（Sports Page Pub）前。马克很兴奋。我很担心。
What's the occasion guys?
“伙计们，是什么日子？”
Just out having fun.
“只是出来玩玩。”
Man of steel. Man of steel, let me tell you. Give you credit.
“钢铁之躯。钢铁之躯，让我告诉你。佩服你。”
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] fight crime.
[听不清] 打击犯罪。
It was Monday, so the bar was only about half full. Most of the people were in their 20s, and they were playing pool. A lot of them had tattoos and piercings. Mark said the crowd looked a little young. He said the outfit does best with people over 40, people who grew up with Superman.
那是周一，所以酒吧只坐了一半。大多数人都在20多岁，他们在打台球。他们很多人有纹身和穿孔。马克说这群人看起来有点年轻。他说这身打扮最适合40岁以上的人，那些看着超人长大的人。
How about a Diet Coke and a Coke, please.
“请给我一杯无糖可乐和一杯可乐。”
Mark, who doesn't drink, gets a soda and goes straight for the area with the most people. In this case, over by the pool tables. He stands there with his Diet Coke and waits for people to approach. Out of the first six people we talked to, four had the same question.
马克不喝酒，他点了一杯苏打水，直接走向人最多的地方。在这种情况下，是在台球桌那边。他拿着他的无糖可乐站在那儿，等待人们走过来。我们交谈的前六个人里，有四个人问了同样的问题。
Do you got a sock in there? No, I'm just kidding, Superman.
“你里面塞了袜子吗？不，我开玩笑的，超人。”
Man of steel.
“钢铁之躯。”
I started to feel really protective of Mark. I wanted to explain to everybody the story of his wife dying. I wanted them to like him. But even though I thought things were going badly, Mark was enjoying himself. Sipping his Coke and fielding questions about the costume.
我开始觉得很想保护马克。我想向每个人解释他妻子去世的故事。我希望他们喜欢他。但尽管我认为事情进展得很糟糕，马克却玩得很开心。喝着他的可乐，回答关于戏服的问题。
I should point out that Mark's in pretty good shape. He looks good in the costume. After we'd been there about 20 minutes, we decided to leave. On the way out we bumped into a group of guys sort of blocking the exit.
我应该指出马克身材保持得很好。他穿上戏服看起来不错。我们在那里待了大约20分钟后，决定离开。在出去的路上，我们撞见了一群挡住出口的家伙。
Are you the weirdo wearing tights?
“你就是那个穿紧身衣的怪胎吗？”
The guy stood chest to chest with Mark for a second. Mark had told me he'd never had anyone try to beat him up before, and I was thinking this might be the first time. Then, before I knew it, the guy was giving Mark a hug. Not a full blown hug. It was one of those, I'm not gay side hugs that guys give each other. Still, it was a pretty big change of attitude for someone who seemed ready to fight 30 seconds earlier. He was saying, dude, it takes a lot of guts to wear that. That sucks about your wife.
那家伙和马克胸对胸站了一秒钟。马克曾告诉我他从未被人打过，我想这可能是第一次。然后，在我不注意的时候，那家伙给了马克一个拥抱。不是那种全套的拥抱。那是那种男人们之间给的“我不基”的侧身抱。尽管如此，对于一个30秒前似乎准备打架的人来说，这态度转变也够大的了。他说：“伙计，穿成这样需要很大勇气。你妻子那事太糟了。”
Up, up, and away.
“向上，向上，远去。”
When people talk to them like this, Mark chalks it up to the costume. But I'm not sure that I agree. I think they actually like him in spite of the costume. He's out there all vulnerable with no defenses and no aggression, and he's excited to be in Spandex leggings and a superhero cape.
当人们这样对他说话时，马克把它归功于这身戏服。但我并不确定我是否同意。我认为他们实际上是喜欢他，而不是因为这身戏服。他赤裸裸地表现自己，没有防御，没有攻击性，而且他因为穿着弹力紧身裤和超级英雄斗篷而感到兴奋。
I don't know all the classic one-liners. I don't know all the current ice breakers. You can go into a bar, and you can be a fly on the wall and just look and watch what everyone's doing. And you can be yourself and not really have to interact with a lot of people. You can turn around and go into that same place with a costume on and everyone just has to interact with you.
“我不了解所有经典的台词。我不知道所有当前的开场白。你可以走进一个酒吧，做个旁观者，看着每个人在做什么。你可以做你自己，并不真正需要和很多人互动。你可以转个身，换个装再次进入同一个地方，每个人都不得不和你互动。”
It helps that he doesn't seem to notice when people laugh at the costume. He assumes that everyone who approaches him is into his outfit. And it's kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy. He acts like they're into it and so he acts nice. And when someone acts so nice, it wins them over.
他似乎注意不到人们笑话这套服装，这也很有帮助。他假设每个接近他的人都对他这身装扮感兴趣。这是一种自我实现的预言。他的表现仿佛人们很感兴趣，所以他表现得很友善。当一个人表现得如此友善时，这就赢得了他们。
Luke Burbank. These days he's trying to reinvent news talk radio with a show called Too Beautiful to Live , which is available as a free podcast at the iTunes store.
卢克·伯班克。最近他正试图重塑新闻访谈电台，开了一档叫《太美而不能活》（Too Beautiful to Live）的节目，在iTunes商店可以作为免费播客获取。
And now the final lesson of our show. Lesson four, Just Be Yourself.
现在是节目的最后一个课程。第四课：做你自己。
Some people are very clear that they are not Superman, and they are at peace with that. And so what if you know that you are just yourself? Just regular size, no special powers. We had the story of one such man whose lack of superpowers is pushed into his face all the time because of circumstances that will become all to clear to you. Jonathan Goldstein tells the story.
有些人很清楚自己不是超人，并且对此感到平和。那么，如果你知道自己只是你自己又如何呢？普通的尺寸，没有特殊的力量。我们有一个关于这样一个男人的故事，由于某种会变得非常清晰的情况，他缺乏超能力的情况一直被摆在他面前。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦讲述了这个故事。
She missed normal men. Lois wanted someone normal. I'm not going to say I won over a class act like Lois Lane through anything other than the fact that I was a normal mortal.
她想念普通男人。露易丝（Lois）想要一个普通人。我不会说我是通过除了我是个普通凡人之外的任何事情赢得了露易丝·莱恩（Lois Lane）这种等级的人的芳心。
She had had her fill of the night rides over Metropolis on Superman's back. She had done the demystifying, I'm letting you get to know the real me trips to the Fortress of Solitude. He had even taken her to Niagara Falls to see the statues made of wax that honored him there. And because she insisted, they took the train. It drove him crazy.
她已经受够了在超人背上飞越都市的夜行。她受够了那种揭秘式的“让你了解真实的我”的孤独堡垒之旅。他甚至带她去尼亚加拉大瀑布看那里为他建造的蜡像。因为她的坚持，他们坐了火车。这让他快疯了。
He would turn to her and say, do you have any idea how ridiculous this is for me? And then he would laugh. He would laugh because he loved her. And despite all of this, she had decided to leave him.
他会转向她说：“你知道对我来说这有多可笑吗？”然后他会笑。他会笑是因为他爱她。尽管如此，她还是决定离开他。
I first met Lois at a charity penny arcade event. At one point in the evening, as I stood hunched over a pinball machine, I looked over to my side and there was Lois Lane. Just standing there, watching me.
我第一次见到露易丝是在一场慈善硬币游乐场活动上。那天晚上，当我弯着腰站在弹球机旁时，我向侧面看去，露易丝·莱恩就在那里。站在那里看着我。
The left flipper wasn't working, so I tried to keep the ball on the right. But when it came down on the left, together we would yell like a couple of kids rolling down the side of the mountain.
左边的挡板坏了，所以我试着让球留在右边。但当它掉到左边时，我们一起大喊，就像两个滚下山坡的孩子。
I've always wanted to reach in there and hold the silver ball in my hand, I said.
“我一直想把手伸进去，握住那颗银色的球，”我说。
I never thought of it that way, said Lois. And five minutes later, she was ripping open a empty pack of Clorets and writing her number down on the white inside.
“我从来没这么想过，”露易丝说。五分钟后，她撕开了一包空的清口糖，把她的电话号码写在了白色的内侧。
Lois was the kind of woman I had always dreamed of. Lois was the kind of woman who made you feel like, I am a man who dates Lois Lane. And as simple as all that sounds, it's the best way I can describe it.
露易丝是我一直梦想的那种女性。露易丝是那种让你觉得“我是个和露易丝·莱恩约会的男人”的女性。听起来虽然简单，但这是我能描述它的最好方式。
At first, I was a novelty. In the beginning, Lois would kiss my forehead and tell me she loved how squishy my arms were. In a good way, she'd say. They're so easy to fall asleep on.
起初，我是一个新鲜感。在最初阶段，露易丝会亲吻我的额头，告诉我她喜欢我的胳膊有多软。她说，是一种好的那种。“它们太容易让人睡着了。”
I wasn't embarrassed by my softness. In fact, all the things my old girlfriends found unattractive and gross about me, Lois found charming.
我不为我的柔软感到尴尬。事实上，我以前的女朋友觉得我不吸引人和恶心的一切，露易丝都觉得很有魅力。
Once I drew eyelashes above my nipples and smeared lipstick around my belly button. Lois swooned as I made my fat gut sing her sweet songs of love. I liked making Lois laugh.
有一次，我在我的乳头上方画了睫毛，在肚脐周围涂了口红。露易丝为我大腹便便、唱着甜美的爱之歌而神魂颠倒。我喜欢逗露易丝笑。
One evening I purchased a jar of olives simply because one of them pressed up against the glass looked like an old man with a little stroke mouth full of pimento. I gave him a voice. I made him say things like, "get me out of here" and "my ass is asleep." Lois appeared to find this delightful.
一天晚上，我买了一罐橄榄，仅仅因为其中一个挤在玻璃杯上看起来像一个留着小胡子、满嘴甜椒的老头。我给了他一个声音。我让他说出像“放我出去”和“我的屁股睡着了”这样的话。露易丝似乎觉得这很令人愉悦。
Although they were broken up, Lois and Superman decided to remain friends. And since they traveled in the same circles, I knew it was only a matter of time before Superman and I would meet. And I knew that when we did, by any possible system of measurement, he would destroy me.
虽然他们分手了，但露易丝和超人决定保持朋友关系。而且因为他们在同一个圈子里活动，我知道我和超人迟早会见面。而且我知道，无论用什么方法衡量，他都会毁了我。
Lois told me that I should expect a call from Superman one of these days. Because he was really anxious to meet me. And several weeks into our relationship, I got the call.
露易丝告诉我，我应该期待哪天接到超人的电话。因为他真的很想见我。在我们开始恋爱几周后，我接到了电话。
When I answered the phone, I felt my chest tighten.
当我接起电话时，我感觉到胸口发紧。
Look, I'd like to keep Lois in my life, he said. And I guess that means we should get to know each other. I don't want to make this into a big deal, but Lois tells me you're between jobs right now, and I could use a sidekick. I'm trying to change my image. I don't want to come off as such a lone wolf anymore.
“听着，我想让露易丝留在我的生活中，”他说。“我想这意味着我们应该互相了解一下。我不想把这变成大不了的事，但露易丝告诉我你现在正处于待业状态，我正需要一个跟班。我正在尝试改变我的形象。我不想再表现得像个孤狼了。”
It would be part-time and I could teach you a thing or two.
“这是兼职的，我可以教你一两招。”
Look, don't get me wrong, I said. You do great things. Wonderful things. And what do I do? If I make it to the post office to buy stamps before noon it's a miracle.
“听着，别误会我的意思，”我说。“你做了伟大的事情。美妙的事情。那我做了什么？如果我能在中午之前赶到邮局买到邮票，那就算奇迹了。”
Silence, he said, cutting me off. But he didn't say it in the way you'd think, all capital letters. He said it quietly, sadly almost.
“沉默，”他说，打断了我。但他说的不是你想的那种大写字母的“沉默”。他说得很轻，几乎带点忧伤。
Silence. Just think about it.
“沉默。好好想想吧。”
When I saw Lois that night for dinner she'd already spoken to Superman. And she was going on about my sidekick-ship like it was already a done deal.
那天晚上吃晚饭时见到露易丝，她已经和超人谈过了。她一直在喋喋不休地谈论我的跟班生涯，仿佛一切已成定局。
It's just what you need to get back on the workforce, she said. And she looked so pleased that before I knew it I was drinking glass after glass of red wine, promising her that it really was no big thing. Lois is just so beautiful when she's pleased.
“这正是你重返工作岗位所需要的，”她说。她看起来如此高兴，以至于我还没反应过来，就在一杯又一杯地喝着红酒，向她保证这真的没什么大不了。露易丝在高兴的时候真是太美了。
The next morning I met Superman for lunch. And before I could sit down in the booth, he handed me a rumpled paper bag.
第二天早上，我和超人去吃午饭。在我坐进卡座之前，他递给我一个揉皱的纸袋。
What's this, I asked.
“这是什么？”我问。
Your new outfit he said. He shooed me off to the bathroom and in the toilet stall, I changed into what was essentially, a skin tight black unitard. There was no cape. The whole thing succeeded in making me look skinny-legged and rotund. Across the chest in small New Courier font was the word "Stewart."
“你的新行头，”他说。他把我赶到洗手间，在厕位里，我换上了基本上一件紧身黑色连体衣。没有斗篷。整个穿着使我看起来腿细而且腹部圆滚滚的。胸前用小号新快递字体写着“斯图尔特”（Stewart）。
I pointed to the name as I walked back to the table.
我走回桌子时指了指这个名字。
It's your sidekick name, Superman said. And you're not supposed to wear underwear with your uniform.
“这是你的跟班名字，”超人说。“而且你的制服里不能穿内衣。”
I spent most of my time wearing my Stewart outfit in his apartment, ironing his costume, fielding calls from the press, and popping boils on his back with a nail and an almanac. And in between, Superman had me doing nonstop sit-ups. He called my gut a crime against humanity.
我大部分时间都穿着我的“斯图尔特”制服在他的公寓里，熨烫他的戏服，回答媒体的电话，用钉子和年鉴帮他挑后背上的疖子。而在间隙，超人让我做不停的仰卧起坐。他称我的肚子是“反人类的罪行”。
His favorite joke was to put his hand on my stomach and ask, how many months?
他最喜欢的笑话是把手放在我的肚子上问：“几个月了？”
But he wasn't perfect either. From up close, Superman stank of Brylcreem and he had this way of getting when he was being all solemn where he would use words like shall and vex. Also, he's really full of himself. But through all of this talk, I would try to maintain eye contact with him. And as I did, I would think to myself, I have seen Lois in her underwear. And tonight when I go home, I might see her in her underwear some more. I wouldn't put it past the bastard to read minds.
但他也不完美。近距离看，超人身上有一股发蜡味，而且他在表现得一本正经的时候有一种习惯，会使用像“应当”和“烦恼”这样的词。而且，他真的很自恋。但透过所有这些谈话，我试图与他保持眼神交流。当我这样做时，我会对自己想：“我已经见过露易丝穿内衣的样子。今天晚上我回家时，我可能会更多地看到她穿内衣的样子。”我可不敢指望那混蛋不会读心术。
As horrible as it all got, in the evening there was Lois. And she seemed so proud of me. But still, Superman was always an unspoken presence between us. I always knew he was out there, feeling better than me. And when I looked at Lois sometimes, I knew she knew I was thinking it. And I guess it sort of made her want to think about it a little herself.
尽管这一切变得多么糟糕，但在晚上，还有露易丝。她似乎为我感到骄傲。但尽管如此，超人始终是我们之间一个不言而喻的存在。我总是知道他在那里，感觉比我好。当我看着露易丝时，有时我知道她知道我在想这件事。我想这让她自己也有点想去想它。
It all came to a head one Thursday night. There was this Thursday night tradition where all the superheroes got together for beer and chicken wings. And on this particular Thursday night, Lois was going to join us.
这一切在星期四晚上达到了顶峰。星期四晚上有一个传统，所有的超级英雄聚在一起喝啤酒、吃鸡翅。在那个特定的星期四晚上，露易丝要加入我们。
The superheroes would sit together at one table, capes all undone, laughing and slapping each other on the back, while the sidekicks sat over at another table, commiserating and trash-talking.
超级英雄们会坐在一张桌子旁，斗篷都解开了，大笑着拍打着彼此的后背，而跟班们则坐在另一张桌子旁，表达共鸣并说对方的坏话。
I looked around my table. There was an angry looking hunchback the Green Lantern worked with and Wonder Woman had brought along a sad-eyed, mousy, colleged-age girl who sat sketching on napkins all night.
我环顾我的桌子。有绿灯侠合作的一个看起来很愤怒的驼背，神奇女侠带来了一个忧郁的、瘦小的大学年纪女孩，她整晚都在餐巾纸上画画。
The Flash had taken on this grizzled old sack of bones who smelled of cabbage and urine that he called Benjamin. Superman told me that Benjamin was the Flash's dad, who the mother had recently thrown out. The Flash was afraid that if he left him alone, he would commit suicide. So he put him in a leotard and took him around with him. Mostly leaving him in the car.
闪电侠带了一个头发花白、闻起来像卷心菜和尿液的老骨头架子，他叫他本杰明（Benjamin）。超人告诉我本杰明是闪电侠的父亲，他母亲最近把他赶出来了。闪电侠担心如果他让他一个人呆着，他会自杀。所以他让他穿上紧身衣，带着他到处跑。大部分时间把他留在车里。
And then, of course, there was Batman's sidekick, Robin. I looked over at them, Superman and Batman, the best of buddies. And I imagined what their conversation was on the night they learned of me and Lois.
然后，当然，还有蝙蝠侠的跟班罗宾。我看着他们，超人和蝙蝠侠，最好的哥们儿。我想象着他们在得知我和露易丝的事那天晚上的对话是什么。
It was as I sat there imagining the two of them laughing at me, their massive upper torsos jerking in a manner that is impossibly manly that I saw Lois walk through the door. Superman caught her eye and she made a beeline right over to him. Instinctively, I rose from my seat. Superman turned to me and our eyes locked.
正当我坐在那里想象着他们两个在嘲笑我，他们巨大的上身以一种不可能的男性化方式抖动着时，我看到露易丝走进了门。超人捕捉到了她的目光，她直接向他走去。我本能地从座位上站了起来。超人转向我，我们的目光锁在了一起。
Much has been written about Superman, but there is an aspect to him that is very difficult to describe. There's a certain feeling one gets when looking into his eyes. And of all the articles I've read, there's nothing that touches on it. It's inhuman and hypnotic. But it's not just that.
关于超人写了很多，但他有一个方面很难描述。看着他的眼睛时，人会产生一种特定的感觉。在我读过的所有文章中，没有任何文章提到过它。它是非人的、催眠的。但这不仅仅是那样。
Being looked at by Superman makes you feel more there than anything, even a dozen TV cameras. And it's not simply that you're there, but that you're there swaddled in layers of reassuringly moistened towelettes. It's comfy and cozy and I cannot explain it well enough.
被超人注视会让你感觉到自己的存在，甚至超过了十几台电视摄像机。不仅是你存在，而是你被包裹在令人放心的湿巾层中。它很舒适、惬意，我无法用语言充分解释清楚。
As she kissed Superman's cheek hello, I turned around and walked out of the bar. Because I was in my Stewart outfit, I didn't even have pockets to dig my fists into.
当她亲吻超人的脸颊问候时，我转身走出了酒吧。因为我穿着我的斯图尔特制服，我甚至连把拳头插进去的口袋都没有。
Sometime after 1:00 in the morning, Lois showed up at my place full of apologies. She had gone over to sit with me, but I had already left. She spent the whole night talking with Superman. She said that he's been really depressed.
凌晨1点多的时候，露易丝出现在我的住处，满是歉意。她本来想过去和我坐在一起，但我已经离开了。她整晚都在和超人聊天。她说他真的很沮丧。
I've never seen him like this, she said. I'm actually a bit worried. He's obsessed with the emptiness of the universe. He said that after we broke up he went looking for God. Literally, looking for God, zipping across the universe, and he came back with nothing.
“我从没见过他这样，”她说。“我其实有点担心。他沉迷于宇宙的空虚。他说我们分手后，他去寻找上帝。字面上寻找上帝，在宇宙中穿梭，但他回来时什么也没找到。”
I wasn't in the mood for a big Superman as a man of constant sorrow routine. But she was clearly on a roll and I didn't have the heart to stop her.
我没心情听那种“超人作为一个持续忧伤的男人”的套路。但她显然说开了，我不忍心打断她。
I never realized how obsessive he can be, she said. He told me there was once a certain way I flipped my hair that so beguiled him he spun around the earth reversing the moment 75,000 times. I never knew that.
“我从没意识到他会如此执着，”她说。“他告诉我，有一次我撩头发的方式是那么吸引他，以至于他绕着地球旋转，将那一刻倒转了75,000次。我从不知道这点。”
I felt myself almost throw up.
我感觉自己差点吐出来。
He's just so intense, she continued. And this planet can be so cold. Did you know that on Krypton when two people fell in love, they became inseparable and they learned to move together in unison? They even had special clothes they wore. He said that on Earth these kinds of garments had names like Fundies and were only sold in the pages of pornographic magazines. Superman says the Earth is a sick, sick place.
“他太强烈了，”她继续说。“而这个星球是如此寒冷。你知道吗？在氪星，当两个人相爱时，他们就变得不可分离，他们学会了一起行动。他们甚至有穿的特殊衣服。他说在地球上，这类衣服有像‘连体裤’这样的名字，而且只在色情杂志上出售。超人说地球是一个病态的、病态的地方。”
My fear wasn't that Lois would get back together with Superman. Because by this point, I knew it was only a matter of time before she would. But that she would describe the summer we spent together as the most miserable, depressing and disgusting time of her life. I already knew how it would infuriate him. I could hear him making stupid jock jokes with her.
我的恐惧不是露易丝会和超人复合。因为到这时，我知道她复合只是时间问题。而是她会把我们在一起度过的那个夏天描述为她一生中最悲惨、最令人沮丧和恶心的时光。我已经知道那会如何激怒他。我能听到他和她讲愚蠢的运动员笑话。
You don't need supervision to see through that sap, he would say.
“你不需要监督就能看穿那个傻瓜，”他会说。
After she went home I decided to take a walk and clear my head. I did so while cursing Superman until there were tears in my eyes. I had only walked a couple of blocks when I ran into Clark Kent.
她回家后，我决定散散步，清醒一下头脑。我这样做的时候一直在诅咒超人，直到我的眼里满是泪水。我只走了几个街区就遇到了克拉克·肯特（Clark Kent）。
I'd been introduced to Clark at a couple of Lois' soirees. And although I hardly know him, he was someone I really liked. He possessed what I felt from my citified point of view was genuine small town warmth, and I just enjoyed being around him.
我在露易丝的几次社交聚会上被介绍给克拉克。虽然我几乎不认识他，但他是我真正喜欢的人。他拥有我从我那种城市观点看来是真正的乡村温暖，我只是喜欢和他在一起。
He told me I looked terribly sad. Terribly sad. People didn't say stuff like that anymore. Having him call me terribly sad instead of depressed or bummed made we already start to feel a little bit better. He asked me if I wanted to grab a beer and I said sure.
他告诉我我看起来非常悲伤。非常悲伤。人们不再说那样的话了。让他叫我“非常悲伤”而不是“沮丧”或“倒霉”，让我已经开始感觉好一点了。他问我是否想去喝杯啤酒，我说当然。
I told Clark all about the evening and he listened to me. That was all I really needed just then, to be listened to.
我告诉克拉克关于晚上的所有事情，他倾听了我的诉说。那是我当时真正需要的，仅仅是被倾听。
How do you know she'll go running back to Superman, asked Clark.
“你怎么知道她会跑回去找超人？”克拉克问。
You should hear the way she talks, I said. Do you have any idea how much Superman can bench press? Superman once went back in time and beat up Hitler. I mean, who can compete with that?
“你应该听听她说话的方式，”我说。“你知道超人能推举多重吗？超人曾经回到过去打败了希特勒。我是说，谁能和那个竞争？”
Clark started laughing so hard people at the other tables turned around to look at us. I was on a roll. With his laughter egging me on I told him all of the things that over the last few weeks I wished I had said to Superman.
克拉克笑得太大声了，以至于其他桌子的人都回过头来看我们。我说得兴起。在他的笑声鼓励下，我告诉了他过去几周里我希望我对超人说过的所有事情。
You're such a phony, I said. You have this idea of what it means to be human, but it's a parody. Humans feel pain, and you don't understand what pain is. You may be super, but you are certainly not a man.
“你真是个骗子，”我说。“你对什么是人类有一个想法，但那是一个讽刺。人类感受到痛苦，而你不理解什么是痛苦。你可能是超级的，但你肯定不是一个人。”
Clark thought that was just perfect. He put his arm around my neck and rocked me back and forth. And we both laughed and laughed.
克拉克认为那真是太完美了。他把胳膊搭在我的脖子上，把我也摇来摇去。我们都笑了又笑。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the the CBC show Wiretap . His book of retold Bible stories comes out this spring.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是加拿大广播公司（CBC）《监听》（Wiretap）节目的主持人。他的重述圣经故事书将于今年春天出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr and Jonathan Goldstein. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
嗯，我们的节目今天由斯塔莉·基恩（Starlee Kine）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和乔纳森·戈尔茨坦也参与了制作。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和[听不清]提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
The music help for this show by Sarah Vowell. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
本节目的音乐帮助由萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）提供。我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. And you know, we remind him over and over--
WBEZ电台对我们节目的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。你知道，我们一遍又一遍地提醒他——
You're not supposed to wear underwear with your uniform.
你的制服里不能穿内衣。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。